il lonfo
il lonfo non va perga e non gruisce
ma molto raramente barigatta
quando soffia il bego a viscepisce si
lecca un poco egnagio sarki patta
ora vi raffiguro subito non sono
completamente a matita quello che ho
fatto è stato recitarvi una breve poesia
una poesia a metà semantica tratta dalle
fanfole Di Fusco Maraini Fosco Maraini
le definiva appunto delle poesie metà
semantiche ovvero delle poesie che sono
in grado di comunicare qualche cosa
andando oltre il significato comune
delle parole infatti Io scommetto che
anche se la maggior parte delle parole
che ho utilizzato non avevano nessun
senso voi ve la sarete creata un po'
un'immagine di questo lonfo tutto frusco
e pieno di lupigna proprio come ce lo
descrive Fosco Maraini cose molto simili
a questa le avrete viste ad esempio nel
teatro di Dario Fo nei film di Chaplin o
anche in televisione con Mr Bean Pingu
tutte situazioni nelle quali Noi siamo
esposti praticamente a dei suoni che di
per sé sono privi di significato però se
Messi all'interno di la struttura semi
linguistica di una cadenza e di una
ritmica molto simile a quella del
linguaggio ci rendiamo conto che sono in
grado di trasmettere comunque un
significato molto chiaro A chi ci
ascolta tutto questo ci fa capire come
il linguaggio e la comunicazione non
sono esattamente la stessa cosa però
sono estremamente interconnessi tra loro
D'altronde comunichiamo di continuo e
non necessariamente con delle parole si
stima che tra il 70 e il 90 per cento
della comunicazione umana sia
completamente non verbale tutto di noi
comunica comunica il modo in cui ci
tagliamo i capelli ci vestiamo
camminiamo su un palco il modo in cui
siamo vicini o lontani da un'altra
persona e il modo in cui le rivolgiamo
uno sguardo e tutto intorno a noi ci
comunica basta pensare che al nostro
cervello è sufficiente solo una frazione
di secondo per guardare il volto di
un'altra persona e capire se è triste
o Gioiosa se è felice di vederci o
arrabbiata con noi
d'altronde la comunicazione non è una
prerogativa dell'essere umano ci sono
tante altre specie animali che sono in
grado di mostrare delle forme di
comunicazione le formiche ad esempio
utilizzano scambi di messaggi che
possono essere tattili o anche sonori
per comunicare Dove è il luogo in cui si
trova un cibo o anche in cui si trova un
pericolo le api utilizzano una speciale
danza per comunicare sempre il luogo in
cui si trova un cibo o anche la sua
forma la sua sostanza Tuttavia Esistono
delle nettissime differenze nel modo in
cui comunica un animale e in cui
comunica l'animale essere umano ad
esempio queste forme di comunicazione
che vedevamo finora non sono
intenzionali difficilmente vedremo
un'ape che punta ad un'altra api e fa
Ehi lo sai che lì ho visto proprio un
gran bel pezzo di fiore
è molto diverso se vogliamo andare poi
ad analizzare quello che il linguaggio
fatto proprio di parole
diversi studi hanno mostrato come ad
esempio uno scimpanzé se è allevato
all'interno di un nucleo familiare umano
è in grado di acquisire un certo numero
di parole di utilizzarle per comporre
una frase e comunicare un messaggio
molto molto semplice sia attraverso
proprio una sorta di voce dei suoni
possiamo dire si attraverso l'uso del
linguaggio dei segni Tuttavia mentre uno
scimpanzé di circa 6 anni maneggia 130
parole un bambino della stessa età ne
maneggia 14 Mila
non Dobbiamo però pensare che la
differenza fra il linguaggio degli
esseri umani e quello finora osservato
negli animali sia quantitativa perché
l'utilizzo del linguaggio è molto più
del mero possesso delle parole noi
utilizziamo il linguaggio per comunicare
di tutto di noi stessi e delle altre
persone lo utilizziamo per comunicare
qualche cosa che è nel qui ed ora ma
anche che magari fa parte del passato
del futuro o che è completamente frutto
della nostra fantasia come una poesia ad
esempio inoltre il linguaggio negli
esseri umani ha un importantissima
funzione anche di coesione sociale
difficilmente possiamo immaginare di
vedere una formica che va dalle sue
colleghe formiche a lamentarsi delle
dure condizioni di lavoro a cui è
sottoposta mentre invece noi esseri
umani Siamo bravissimi ad andare dai
nostri amici a lamentarci di tutto
quello che ci è capitato nelle nostre
vite
il linguaggio se lo guardiamo poi da una
prospettiva neuroscientifica possiamo
dire che è strettamente legato alla
nostra capacità di ragionare e di
pensare Ora non dobbiamo pensare che
esistono delle gerarchie di complessità
fra lingue semplici e lingue complesse
né fra lingue ufficiali e lingue
dialettali però diversi studi hanno
mostrato come ad esempio chi parla più
di una lingua ha anche una memoria più
lunga o è in grado di risolvere problemi
in modo più creativo Se guardiamo al
neurosviluppo Sappiamo benissimo anche
dall'esperienza Insomma di vita
quotidiana come i bambini iniziano ad
utilizzare un vero e proprio linguaggio
verso la fine del primo anno di vita e
questo succede Non per caso succede
perché è proprio allora che sono
riusciti ad avere una struttura
cognitiva e anche semantica complessa al
punto tale da permettere
l'implementazione di questo linguaggio
e pensiero non sono quindi esattamente
la stessa cosa sono molto interconnessi
ma non dobbiamo pensare che però in
assenza di linguaggio ci sia anche
assenza di pensiero
esiste una condizione nota come afasia
globale che affligge Chi ha subito una
lesione alla corteccia temporale
sinistra che quella parte del nostro
cervello Che presiede alle nostre
capacità linguistiche in questa
condizione i pazienti che ne sono
affetti si trovano nella totale
incapacità sia di comprendere che di
produrre il linguaggio Tuttavia queste
persone non smettono di ragionare Non
smettono di pensare sono in grado di
empatizzare con i propri cari sono in
grado di apprezzare della buona musica e
anche di risolvere un problema logico
linguaggio e pensiero quindi non sono la
stessa cosa ma sono interconnessi
potremmo dire che questa
interconnessione è data da un misto di
biologia e ambiente la biologia ci
fornisce le basi che ci permettono sia
di poter apprendere un linguaggio che di
poterlo usare ma il modo in cui noi poi
utilizziamo questo linguaggio dipende
estremamente dall'ambiente plasma
potremmo dire ed è a sua plasmato
dall'ambiente
numerose evidenze Infatti sottolineano
come la lingua che parliamo ci dà le
parole che ci servono per categorizzare
quindi interpretare il mondo che ci
circonda ad esempio una persona italiana
come me riesce molto più velocemente a
distinguere tutte le sfumature del
colore che possono andare dall'azzurro
fino al blu in una frazione di tempo
abbastanza rapida rispetto ad una
persona madrelingua inglese che invece
utilizza solo la parola blu per
descrivere tutte queste possibili
sfumature quindi sia quella più chiara
che quella più scura di questo colore e
questo avviene proprio
all'in virtù di questa intrinseca
connessione fra quella che è il bagaglio
linguistico che ci portiamo dietro e
quella che è la nostra esperienza
percettiva Infatti questo tipo di
evidenze ci mettono in mostra come
questa interconnessione non si verifica
solo in qualcosa di estremamente
semplice basilare come appunto la
percezione del colore o la percezione di
una forma ma anche in funzione cognitive
molto più complesse come ad esempio la
capacità di orientarci nello spazio e di
orientarci nel tempo e perfino di
provare delle emozioni le parole che il
nostro bagaglio linguistico ci mette a
disposizione per descrivere le emozioni
determinano tantissimo sia di come noi
stessi le viviamo in prima persona sia
di quanto ad esempio siamo più o meno
disposti a condividere le esternarle nei
confronti delle altre persone
e tutto questo è frutto è evidenza
proprio
dell'interconnessione continua che c'è
fra biologia e ambiente
il linguaggio quindi Getta le basi del
nostro pensiero ma la relazione è
bidirezionale perché non determina e
influenza solo il nostro pensiero ma
anche il pensiero di chi ci ascolta io
potrei descrivere uno stesso evento con
parole diverse e trasmettere due
messaggi completamente opposti Se ad
esempio io dico che Patrizia è in
ritardo Mi sto limitando a descrivere un
fenomeno un evento se io invece dico che
Patrizio è una ritardataria sto dicendo
molto di più sto insinuando nella mente
di chi mi sta ascoltando che quella non
è la prima volta che è successo e che
probabilmente Capiterà ancora una volta
In altre parole sto insinuando sto
suggerendo una qualità permanente di
quella persona e non a caso stereotipi e
pregiudizi sono trasmessi soprattutto
attraverso il linguaggio
ora badate bene spesso questo tipo di
espressioni noi le utilizziamo in
maniera del tutto spontanea e
inconsapevole ma non dobbiamo
dimenticarci del fatto che possono
essere usate in maniera completamente
consapevole proprio per manipolare il
nostro pensiero
ad esempio è noto che io posso aumentare
il consenso di un pubblico compiacente
utilizzando delle parole dei verbi che
rimandano a qualche cosa di eterno
immutabile così come Io invece posso
ridurre il dissenso se sto parlando con
un pubblico che ha opinioni
completamente diverse dalle mie
utilizzando invece delle parole che si
riducono al qui ed ora che mi sembrano
assolutamente
convertibili nel giro di poco tempo
all'interno di un'aula di tribunale
l'avvocato della Difesa dirà che Andrea
ha dato uno schiaffo mentre l'avvocato
dell'accusa dirà che Andrea è una
persona violenta
Purtroppo però questi non sono dei
banali esempi ma sono delle realtà
diverse studi hanno dimostrato come
operazioni linguistiche di questo genere
sono in grado di influenzare tanto il
consenso politico quanto il giudizio di
colpevolezza innocenza di una persona in
un'aula di tribunale un qualche cosa che
dovrebbe dipendere solo Dai fatti e non
dalle parole che vengono utilizzate per
descrivere quei fatti
il linguaggio ha il potere di plasmare
la nostra realtà ed insinuare idee
all'interno della nostra mente nel film
Inception Christopher Nolan si chiede
attraverso le domande le parole di
Leonardo Di Caprio Qual è il parassita
più resistente al mondo e la conclusione
alla quale giungono e che non è un virus
o un batterio ma è un'idea un'idea
perché un'idea una volta che ha preso
piede nel nostro cervello è quasi
impossibile da eradicare
e la cosa più sorprendente è che per
instillare un'idea è sufficiente una
parola
Provate a non pensare ad un elefante o
alla posizione che in questo momento
alla vostra lingua mentre vi sto dicendo
di non farlo
è praticamente impossibile
ora non mi dovete rispondere
Ma qual è l'immagine che si crea nella
vostra mente se io vi dico passeggiatore
oppure se io vi dico passeggiatrice
se io vi dico figlio di una buon uomo
oppure figlio di una buona donna
il linguaggio è un grande potere e come
tutti i supereroi ben sanno Da grandi
poteri derivano grandi responsabilità
proprio per questo dobbiamo essere
costantemente consapevole delle parole
che utilizziamo Innanzitutto nei nostri
pensieri e inoltre nelle interazioni che
noi abbiamo con gli altri le parole
possono essere in grado di permetterci
di valicare confini politici religiosi e
culturali ma possono anche innalzare
muri e barriere laddove questi muri e
queste barriere dovrebbero essere
distrutti Invece proprio per questo
dobbiamo chiederci costantemente Quali
sono le parole delle quali vogliamo
circondarci Quali sono le parole che noi
vogliamo utilizzare per creare una
narrativa costruttiva e positiva che
riesca a guidare siano gli stessi che le
persone che ci circondano verso il tipo
di mondo che vogliamo contribuire a
costruire e ad avere intorno a noi
grazie
[Applauso]